[Musique]
à l'occasion de la foire agricole la
commission permanente a décentralisé ses
travaux bras panon ce mercredi 15 mai le
président cyrille melchior s'est réjoui
de cette matinée traduisant le soutien
fort de la collectivité au monde
agricole
chaque année le département veut faire
la démonstration que notre agriculture
et de qualité une agriculture de qualité
qui va être soutenue aussi bien par nous
département que par les autres comme
l'union européenne à travers le feader
et donc quand je vois les produits de
qualité des produits pays et produit
kluïev ses fruits et légumes cette
viande de qualité
on est rassuré et on se dit que le
département d'aller toujours encore plus
loin ou à soutenir l'agriculture pays
les élus sont ensuite allés à la
rencontre des agriculteurs et ont visité
les différents stands la portance pour
nous d'être aux côtés de plus proche des
agriculteurs c'est d'être présente ici
sur ce champ de foire et je crois que
une nouvelle fois le conseil
départemental vient réaffirmer son
soutien et sa volonté d'être la
locomotive dans la politique agricole à
la réunion moi je suis de ceux qui
souhaitent que de plus en plus nous
soyons des élus de proximité des élus où
nous sommes en contact de la population
nous rencontrons nous souhaitons
dialoguer est interpellé et en même
temps montré mais nous les pareil tout
le monde
aujourd'hui nous avons pu la
responsabilité ses responsabilités ses
décisions elles doivent être prises au
coeur même de la réunion chaque année le
département consacre 10 7 millions
d'euros à l'agriculture réunionnaise
auxquels s'ajoutent l'europe et les
fonds feader dont la gestion relève
également de notre collectivité
[Musique]